the Father the Son and the Holy Ghost
I've a Tommy Wiseau's dialogue coach
with dr. Nick Riviera which takes us to
our bonus well let's count up every time
Tommy says hi here we go hi men and I
say hi oh hi pillow fighting equals
foreplay god Danny is a creepy bastard
perfectly clear day just two minutes ago
now reigning naval come on we're talking
about age we're talking about lesion the
stairs are the best place to hit the
g-spot when laying down the soundtrack
the record skipped oh hi Johnny I didn't
know was you the flower shop owner
doesn't know it's Johnny even though no
one on the entire earth looks like
Johnny you're my favorite custom so what
was up with not recognizing me can I
kiss you
holy Denny is a creepy bastard she's
kidding
holy shit Denny is a creepy bastard
Connie was Oh reads lines he wrote like
he doesn't understand them think I will
ever get it they betrayed me
they didn't keep their promise they
tricked me and I don't care anymore the
best drink to give someone who doesn't
drink is a combination of scotch and
vodka if you love me you'll drink this
that's how the Jonestown Massacre
started you're right a scotch guy is not
your mother's cooking you do not need to
lie about scotch guy Tommy was oh cuts
and pastes the same I'm sex scene into
the movie Lisa suddenly grows a vagina
in her hip God is clearly angry at
Johnny and Lisa having sex Lisa's mom
buries the lead about having breast
cancer also the movie buries breast
cancer Lisa's plan was to get Johnny
drunk so he might hit her but when he
doesn't hit her she lies about it anyway
why are we even talking about this oh
yeah Lisa loves Mark and doesn't like
Johnny anymore time for a bonus round
very much I love you I love mark because
I'm in love with mark I like you very
much mark I'm in love with mark you know
I love you very much I love you I love
you I don't love him me I don't love
Johnny I don't love him anymore
well I don't want to marry him anymore I
don't have any more feelings for Johnny
I don't love Johnny anymore I don't even
like him
not Johnny but I don't love him who the
fuck are these people
this guy gets cross-eyed before the BJ
how many people come in and out of this
apartment every day good question I also
need a cup of flour and a half a stick
of butter
doesn't your home have a kitchen don't
your breasts have cancer
this camera move should be impossible
beer in a few minutes
Cris are has to carefully consider what
the money is coming means before he gets
angry about it good thing Lisa and her
mom aren't there oh wait yeah they are
mark and Johnny has scored a dangerous
criminal to jail by themselves calm down
he's going to jail sure the police just
accept anybody you say needs to be in
jail money could be used for goods and
services
how are you giving them to him selling
I'm joined it's Deni that owes the money
Wow Johnny and Marc booked Cris are in
the county jail in record time good
thing Marc isn't there oh wait yeah he
is I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark
the sight of Mark always called Johnny
whether he's being accused of domestic
abuse or not well we'll see Danny don't
blame too much it may not come out right
what the fuck did you just say actually
it doesn't matter San Franciscans love
their football as you'll find out so are
you ready for some football
I think I'm in love with her Johnny
doesn't think it's odd when his creepy
friend Denny expresses love for Lisa
what about Elizabeth ah expresses love
for Lisa then says that Elizabeth is the
one I want to marry yeah Tammy part Lisa
there's nothing wrong with this scene
this is gold good night Johnny yeah
don't slip on the semen on the way up
tragedy tragedy equals someone
discovering your underwear we were we
were making out at your place
johnny is unfazed at the news that other
people fuck in his apartment he pulls it
out and she's showing everybody in the
underwears all three people in the room
what is up with this scene Lisa her mom
come into the room specifically to say
all this about Johnny and then leave
everything Johnny says he'll record
everything so tape recorder magically
appears also carries around a cassette
in his shirt pocket at all times yep
this is how phone calls are recorded
hook up a tape recorder to a phone and
the tape never runs out who the fuck is
this guy
the Geo the door the doorbell just rang
face linen man women just confuse me yes
this is a very suspicious thing to say
here
you always play psychologist with us he
is a psychologist
don't you remember saying but you are
psychologist this is the opposite effect
of marijuana use greg zarcero in reefer
madness - sorry yeah we just go a little
mad sometimes
for tea and slitting what client no I
can anyway how is your sex life talking
about his confidential bank partners
really gets Johnny's mind in the gutter
mark has finally graduated to the top of
the stairs come on Johnny's my best
friend mark seems to forget he's in a
sexual relationship with Lisa in almost
every scene I have everything covered
your point of view is so different from
mine look I don't want to talk about it
see where this reaction makes sense
currently located near Jimmy Hoffa I
don't see what the big deal is doesn't
everybody look out for never there's a
line of dialogue for every grocery item
in this scene the Lisa suddenly grow a
vagina in her brain I'm crazy
everybody's here and they'll be outside
forever and ever because this guy you
have got to be honest with Johnny I
agree with that
who is this guy there is no baby I told
them that to make it interesting lisa
has lots of great ideas
I don't think Mark really loves you
Lisa's mom's breast cancer knows more
about mark than this guy does okay
enough with the plans to get everybody
out of the room let's just start making
out in front of them here's that
cassette with six months worth of tape
on it does Johnny really need to prove
Lisa's infidelity after hearing her
admit it two times already yeah yeah get
out and I don't care about the baby
anymore either probably pretty close to
what Lisa is actually like
this should have been done before the
script was written yes it's dead you
don't need to be a doctor to declare
somebody dead you just need to be able
to read bloody fingers have me you'll
never have me there's mark forgetting he
had sex with Lisa one more time for once
I agree as far as I know sir you could
drop off the earth that's a promise
mark just couldn't leave this movie
without saying one more thing that
didn't make sense Danny is still a
creepy bastard
why did you do this to me